primo appuntamento pensato a un posto
carino ammazza bella merda sembra un
bunker post atomico è senza veli la
facciamo prima a rovistare in un
cassonetto
io volevo fare loro un gesto romantico
portarti in un posto intimo te lo dico
io il posto di timo sarà l'unica cosa
intima che vedrà stasera è perché dopo
che mi ha portato in stato taglia col
cazzo vettel a small ma a beneficio ma
tu pensi che se una persona che
oggettificazione in questo modo e tutto
il team è preso più per telethon bisogno
riferiscono la carta dei vini vino c'è
chi lo ama e chi lo odia c'è chi lo
preferisce bianco che io preferisce
rosso il rosè
ecco diciamo che quest'ultima categoria
merita di perdere l'uso delle papille
gustative perché sa che mi servono no ma
io adori rosa re legale per l'italia ma
che ne so fatto che stasera mi sento un
po contrabbandiera io adori rosa che ho
capito ti piacciono altre cose note
rosano city la falsa rosa la salsa rosa
si è il frattale la frase deve essere
stato terribile per i tuoi genitori che
cosa propria parte il cervello tutte le
mure io adori da moriva da tutti gli
animali rosa ma c'è una categoria di
persone che mi mette più ansia di quelli
che amano il rosa che sono quelli che mi
chiedono scegliere il pino sente un po
rendite utile giovanni mucciaccia su
ordine il vino a ok ma biancorosso
grafica e tanto devo capito ma allora
cioè non ovvero marco io ho detto ordina
quel cazzo di vino durante gli anni ho
capito che la prima cosa da non far
solamente quando bisogna scegliere il
vino è quella di guardare il prezzo
perché se capitate a cena con una
persona orribile state certi che questa
qui aspetterà il momento esatto in cui
vostri occhi scatteranno sul prezzo
perché si vede quando scattano
scusami
scusami che vogliamo fare vogliamo
ordinare un piatto di polistirolo
vogliamo vogliamo bere dell'acqua
piovana
non lo so direttamente portarla dal
kebabaro vero volto appare notte mani
direttamente trovajoli no guardi guardi
scuti pepe per me possiamo assolutamente
finirla qui non lo so facevo prima
uscire con lei è certo ok magari lo
succede proprio questo ma se volete fare
i fighi e sappiate che la tecnica da
utilizzare questi casi è quella
dell'allora un occhio esperto non avrai
notato nulla ma riguardiamo secondo il
rallenty prendete la carta dei vini
bevande a leggete velocemente
portatevi una mano alla tempia fingendo
un principio improvviso di emicrania
leggete velocemente quali sono i prezzi
ad un calcolare la velocità del suono e
a quel punto scegliete non il più
economico perché da pezzenti il terzo
più ecologico o un pecorino grazie al
seta zampata aggiungendo commento
apprezzamento bonsai
amo il pecorino beh io ho provato la sua
renna del pecorino che viene mai uscita
insoddisfatti ma quando partono il vino
evitate di fare i sommelier cioè a meno
che non lo siate davvero evitate la
mossa della lavatrice neri capelli fare
come se fosse usciti dalla rehab evitati
e metodi di assaggi un ponte nei rari
senti scusa ma una bottiglia di pinot
grigio un flacone di lisp ed in quello
piuttosto stata una gittata secca una
musata veloce veloce e così source e
tiro al volo ed evitare commenti tipo
che mano in passato mi hanno spiegato
con vero intenditore dovrebbe sempre
dire cose tipo va bene è perfetto ottimo
player un vero intenditore perché
praticamente la morella favore che il
vino è sempre buono deve andare bene con
l'accoppiata di di piatti quindi
teoricamente dovresti anche ordinarlo
dopo aver scelto le bilance non
all'inizio a bestie ghazi io
personalmente una cosa che amo fare
quando si aggiungono anche se
il tavernello un bicchiere di aceto di
mele e sempre angeles tumore
wow pazzesco non chiedetemi perché lo
faccia ma nonostante sento ogni volta un
grandissimo intenditore oppure qualche
volta rimango improvvisamente assorto
nei miei pensieri come se stessi non lo
so cercando di decifrare la stele di
rosetta anche questo mi fa sentire un
grandissimo figo scherzi a parte la cosa
bella del vino e che tutti lo devono ma
nessuno ci capisce un ca io sinceramente
amo analizzare la location cioè capire
quando bisogna optare per il vino della
casa e quando invece sarebbe meglio
sfruttare la cartella umiltà se dunque
cosa mi consigli a guardi non ci capisco
un cazzo
bene e anche se suona un pochino come
una metafora della vita
rimarrò sempre l'opinione che quando s'è
accesa con qualcuno non è importante
scegliere il pino milioni del mondo
quanto preoccuparsi di versarlo a
persona gravante ogni sua del bicchiere
così presto capito e se il vino vi mette
ansia andate di birra e se siete a samyn
pubblica timidi baci sole cuore amore
evviva la pace nel mondo da grande
voglio fare il veterinario con la
ballerina con il pollaio oil colla rolo
il bacio è l'apostrofo rosa tra le
parole ti è ammontato a commutare le
parole ti cam e la fase però le parole
tabù
ti amo era anche una frase di merda